well let me kind of ask a hard question
- you've lost your dad a few years ago
yeah
what did it feel like when you learned
that he died what went through your head
what memories well like you know losing
your parents it's losing your parents so
I would say what I can say it's a losing
paradin and my father it was a whole
generation you know it's just like a and
you know the feeling you have that now
you are the man that's interesting that
you like feeling is now it's my trying
to be great now just I have to do
something now just because when you have
your parents you always have this
feeling that there is something behind
you just in case
yeah and my father he was very very very
strong personality just this interesting
story that during this Jews persecution
in 1952 by Stalin when it was so called
a fear of doctors or whatever how to say
in English deliberately when Jewish
people were actually said just their
doctors and okay most of doctors were
Jewish Wesley so they used to say that
they actually kill half of the
government whatever as a doctors it was
absolutely lie it just says nothing with
reality and Jews they were prepared
actually to be moved from all over so it
Union to be a beach on to like a close
to Chinese border on a more River like
oh it's already they try to move them
closer to Japan to Japanese whiskey so
like in camps know what just just just
just kind of move them straight to the
so called the Jewish
Oh blessed Jewish region or whatever but
it's like it was nothing there yeah and
if you move like this kind of group of
people I was about three million Jews
forget you know at least half who will
die just during this moving so it was
nice and you're preventing them from
having a future yeah so at that time you
know people they kept start kept talking
about the same stupid stuff that Jews a
drink blood of babies of Christian
babies yeah and and that's what my
father used to say that his friends and
it's like you know it's like a meeting
and you know people are asking have you
seen something have you seen him like a
drinking blood or something like that
and he said that he was absolutely in
products his friends and all of them
they mostly I mean they are or either
leaving the room just not to participate
in this stupidity war they say we
haven't seen but who knows if people
they write in newspapers is a very
strong propaganda so they he lost he was
a associate director of this
manufacturing plant and they say that
he's supposed to leave because because
this whole propaganda he's a Jew and
choose a drink in the blood of Christian
baby
maybe maybe who knows but yes maybe it's
enough that there's no evidence that
they're not yes right so so he is not
going to prison but he is not going to
work in our enterprise so he said ok I
am like a social director and I want to
be a worker a simplest water but because
I love my plasticity no
so actually he left it was what was that
memory standout for you why because it
was it was 1952 and I was born in 1953
so just so what was happening that he
was without job for one year because
nobody wanted to to take him before
Stalin died in 1953 it wasn't meant when
I was born so my mother she worked to
support the whole family and we lived in
a small room 14 square meters it was my
grandmother grandfather father mother
and me
so the I mean the it's kind of it was a
big impact on and then Stalin died and
everything become way better it is and
in terms of anti-semitism as well you
see there is a good movie by the way
made here in America a Russian Jews part
1 or part 2 Russian news part 3
I think it's on YouTube version yeah so
what is that it was almost no
anti-semitism before World War 2 right
it was very strong anti-semitism after
the end of the world war 2 and in 1945
and deaths of Stalin in 1953 in 1953
serration become better but not as good
way not as good as in the nineteen
thirties
why was there anti-semitism after the
war the Second World War
it seems the idea how did Russia sorry
to interrupt how did Russians in your
memory think about the the the cruelty
of the Holocaust because there's so much
pride about Russia winning the war of
being the you know to getting to Berlin
isn't how do you think about the people
that were tortured
well well holiday very strong very
strong propaganda propaganda very strong
propaganda so what happened that okay
what actually happened that in the end
of okay before World War two yeah before
world war ii actually jewish people they
just they forgot that their juice it was
mmm I mean they were all Soviet like a
little bit first Soviet first way way
first I mean it was before were in the
end of the war Jewish people they create
a lot of special organizations and
because of Holocaust they had
significant support of United States of
America and Western countries but most
United States of America and Jewish
people in the end of over tool they
start thinking that it's like my story
with this when I graduated from high
school so they started believing that
they are big guys you know because I
have so much support from the United
States and it's also and on top of that
like a cherry it was a creation of
Israel right I was around and so and I
did 49 there's there's a kind of a push
that Jews are no longer Soviets they
their homeland is yes and and Jews a
felt like initially very nice but they
overdid it
so bottom line it was a and also don't
not to forget about Hitler so as a
result a level of anti-semitism in from
1945 to 1953 was growing significantly
then it was a little bit better but
actually significant improvement starts
happening only in 1960s
not earlier than that so can you talk a
little bit more about your dad's journey
in World War 2 I mean there's I remember
a bunch of stories but you know just for
people interested you know is World War
2 is at the core of our family in a
sense so can you just linger and maybe
if you have memories about it his impact
how did he get injured
what was his relationships with you know
violence with death was bullets flying
everywhere
yeah my father he was born in 1923
so in night and we're in Minsk in Minsk
which is now with Russia and he was born
in October so when world war started he
was 17 and it was forbidden to go to
army if you are younger than 18 so
together with his friends they may
change in the passport they just change
their year from they made himself one
year older just to be accepted to the
army and interesting enough that like
the way I understand at least these
people who organized like a army they
understand they saw that this boys are
younger but they let go he wanted to go
what he wanted to go you know there's so
many stories and you know more in
America where there's there's a lot of
people brave people who found ways to
not go yeah here it's absolutely
opposite
it's absolutely opposite because most
well not not everybody over this one but
majority propaganda was extremely strong
so protecting your father and mother one
it's even to die for your country yes
yes yes so to die for your country it
was kind of like an honor
yeah ads and also they were sure that's
Red Army is hundred times stronger than
this
Germans yeah so and they thought that
okay we'll go there so a couple of
months and we are winners but in one way
or another but they were wanted to go
especially when you know you're not like
a very rich guy you know so he went to
the army and it was like a couple of
months special preparation to become
like a lowest level of officers so
junior lieutenant or whatever it is in
this country and he became like this low
level officer and he starts actually I
near Moscow and just start going back
and back and back and back and that's it
and he was with this machine gun big one
and you know the change of like it was
very fast so people they were killed
very very very fast actually people that
were operating machine guns yeah ah very
very fast because just finish the
changeover
so he became division commander
reasonably fast decisions read you know
that's one way to move up when
everybody's dying yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
and what he kept saying I think even to
you because he just it was like he kept
saying that for some reason he was
absolutely sure that every year he sold
it like everybody else had killed and
he's not so he was kind of sure that
something is protecting him he's
invincible and yes he's invincible he he
might wasn't writing and he was very
strong actually very very very strong
like by the way physically and mentally
physically and mentally so kind of like
helix I mean he is like because this
dude would not like myself but he is
very physically strong and mentally
protected like I don't know what best
way to say that he's he was sure in
himself and he was sure that there's a
confidence is that yeah yeah yeah no no
no it's not it's a confidence it's a
concern a little bit like a kind of like
a religious but he he did not believe to
the gap in the first place come but he
believed in what he used to say in his
star services there is a star which
protects him and I'd be right and he
might be right
he survived the war he got he survived
war because after like for no like five
or six months he was heavily wounded
which was very good yeah actually
because that's right he's right in the
leg in the leg yeah so he was like and
he had a lot of this horse
do you remember what about the people in
general you know 20 million plus Soviet
people died what impact do you remember
what impact the war had on the people to
Norma's enormous that's why for 20
meeting it is a lot and as anybody half
of them were just civilians because
Stalin he just operated this war without
counting people yeah but do you think it
had powerful creative impact in terms of
music art literature the science a sad
thing about war well all of the above
science mostly all of the above
it because even before war science was
very much pushed up but after the war
scientists they were considered like the
key people in the world especially
military scientists
well I don't think I've ever asked you
this I haven't asked you most of the
things I'm asking but you're Jewish
Hitler killed a lot of Jews how did you
feel about the Holocaust I don't think
we've actually really talked about is it
just an intellectual tragedy to you or
did it ever feel I know I but what do
you think about human nature after that
who is he that I have parents
and my parents they have parents which
my grandparents and they're my
great-grandparents so all of those all
of those without exception were killed
in Holocaust zero died with their own
death natural death all of them they
were killed because they were like
already a little bit older like I am now
and they were sure that Germans they
will not touch them come on just do
something to hold people itself strange
and all of them without exception all of
know they were killed so it is you know
like initially in my life I just it was
like a really hatred with respect to
Germans in general which only later I
mean it was clear that it's not it's not
say it's not German in Germany but
that's but it was very serious feelings
about that
so hatred but so as you as you grew up
did it
are you hopeful about whether people are
good or evil and did that have a impact
on you know the fact that you can see so
much evil
you can become cynical the way you still
did you is there still an optimistic
positive person inside you yeah there is
I am optimistic myself I am optimistic
so just like the point is that like a I
was when I just start growing up even
even in high school level of
anti-semitism was like a way lower and
in general I felt myself always way more
Soviet then I was a Russian Ukrainian or
Jewish or
you